jesse
it's such a big house and all
jessie
you rang
23 years after the parent trap's release
actresses elaine hendricks and lisa ann
walter are proving they've still got it
you rang
the former co-stars and close pals
linked up to recreate the iconic scene
all on elaine's tick tock you'll recall
it's the moment at nick parker's napa
estate elaine plays his much younger
fiance meredith and lisa his trusty
housekeeper jesse
you rang
but it's not the first time elaine has
channeled the feisty blonde character
that put her on the map
if we don't get started soon i'm taking
one large sleeping pill and going to bed
that's it i am taking one large sleeping
pill and going to bed
last month the 50 year old actress
posted a tick tock in defense of her
polarizing character it's been 20 long
years since my engagement to nikki ended
so i think it's finally time to clear
the air on some things that have been
said about me for years
speaking in character elaine debunks the
myth that meredith was a gold digger
i had a fantastic job as a major
publicist in san francisco i ran okay i
didn't need nick parker's money plus
anyone with eyes could see that like his
wine that man was getting better with
age and i'll say it he was a certified
dilf that's right and she hilariously
pokes fun at nick's parenting strategy
that was real normal not telling your
kid they've had a twin and then not
realize they came home from summer camp
completely different in almost every
discernible way
yeah
that's not suspect at all
and this line is so good it needs no
explanation
and if being compared to a strong
fashion forward successful woman makes
me cruella
then fetch me a dalmatian and a
cigarette holder pronto got it cruella
the beloved nancy meyers classic
celebrated its 20th anniversary in 2018.
at the time et spoke with nick parker
himself dennis quaid who reflected on
the experience of making the film that
was such a huge movie i love that movie
yes yeah um i really do do you have a
memory of working on set with natasha
and lindsay oh yeah natasha i really
miss her she was so fantastic
and just what a wonderful wonderful
spirit she was
in this world and
we all miss her
that uh i remember lindsay uh you know
it was i think
just really her first job and she was
just
i was just
amazed at her and
when i saw the film you know because one
has an english accent and one's in an
american accent i
when i saw the film i i knew the real
deal but i thought there was two girls
that's the way i felt she made me forget
all the time
[Music]
you